- So, this year you celebrated the,
is it your 30th year?
- Yes, on "Days of Our Lives,"
Don't do the math on that.
(crowd cheering)
- Like, you pretty much find
people you like to work with,
and you stay.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm loyal.
I stick around.
- That's really good though,
that means, also, that it's
a great environment, so that's awesome.
What do you think
about 30 years?
- I feel like I grew up
playing this character,
playing Sami Brady.
I started when I was 16 years old.
- Oh my God.
- And I was just
a dopey kid, and I just loved it.
I love my job, I love working there,
the crew, like, all watched me grow up,
and get married, and have my own kids,
and then now I get to go
back every once in a while,
and visit, and you do get that sense
of just reuniting with everyone again.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's wonderful.